More bio-prank than biopic , "Weird: The Al
Yankovic Story" parodies movie biographies of
musicians just like "Weird Al" parodies hit songs.
Fans and critics wouldn't want it any other way.
The origins of "Weird: The Al Yankovic Story"
date back to 2010, on Funny or Die. The minds
behind it put together a trailer for a then-fake
movie of the same name with Aaron Paul from
"Breaking Bad" portraying the titular musician.
It garnered some attention online at the time,
but didn't seem to be anything more than
a one-off sketch. Fast forward 12 years,
and "The Al Yankovic Story" is a reality.
"'Bohemian Rhapsody' had come out, and
'Rocketman' was about to come out, so,
you know, Al thought it was the right time."
"Weird" is essentially a parody of music biopics
about a musician who's made a career out of
song parodies. According to a trailer for the
film, "Weird" will tell the sensationalized and
extremely untrue story of the rise and fall of
Yankovic, including how he was discovered in a
club, devised his first parody on the spot,
allowed himself to be seduced by Madonna,
and descended into a haze of drugs, alcohol, and
arrests. Very little of which really happened.
To pull off an epic tale of fame, love, and
polka, "Weird: The Al Yankovic Story" has
assembled quite a cast. First and foremost
is Harry Potter himself, Daniel Radcliffe,
who The Hollywood Reporter revealed signed
on to play Yankovic in January 2022.
"How, like, well versed are you on the accordion?"
"Much better than I was three months ago."
Rainn Wilson of "The Office" joins him as his
mentor, syndicated radio show host Dr. Demento,
with Evan Rachel Wood as Madonna,
Quinta Brunson as Oprah Winfrey,
and Spencer Treat Clark as Yankovic's
longtime bassist, Steve Jay. Toby Huss
and Julianne Nicholson will portray Yankovic's
anti-accordion parents, Nick and Mary Yankovic.
That's just the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to the comedic talent on display in
the cast. One name that's missing, though,
is Aaron Paul. The "Westworld" star nearly
had a spot in the film to honor his role
in the original "Funny or Die" sketch,
but his cameo never came to pass.
In an interview with CinemaBlend,
Paul explained that a bout of COVID-19
prevented him from appearing. He said,
"I couldn't do it, and then I was just out for
like 10 solid days. I have never felt more sick
in my life. And so we couldn't do the cameo,
which I just absolutely was crushed about."
Principal photography on "The Al Yankovic
Story" kicked off in February 2022,
according to an Instagram post from Yankovic.
By early March, filming had already wrapped,
Yankovic later posted on Twitter. After
spending a few months in post-production,
"The Al Yankovic Story" will become available for
viewing on November 4, 2022, in the United States.
The film made its theatrical debut at the Toronto
International Film Festival in September, but
there aren't going to be too many other theatrical
showings. "The Al Yankovic Story" will drop as an
exclusive on the Roku Channel. The streamer comes
free with the purchase of a Roku stick or box,
but folks who don't have either of those can
also access The Roku Channel via a web browser.
Eric Appel directed "Weird: The Al
Yankovic Story," and it's difficult
to imagine a better choice. After all,
he's the one that spearheaded the original
sketch that got the ball rolling all
those years ago. Appel also boasts an
impressive and varied résumé that extends
well beyond the reaches of Funny or Die.
In addition to a number of Funny or Die sketches,
he's also jumped to television and helmed
episodes of "New Girl," "The Office," "Son
of Zorn," "The Grinder," "Blue Mountain State,"
and "Brooklyn Nine-Nine," among numerous other
well-known network and cable programs. Appel has
worked as a writer, producer, and editor as well,
though he isn't always behind the camera. He's
tried his hand at acting on a small handful of
occasions and last appeared on an episode
"Nick Swardson's Pretend Time" in 2010.
Appel also wrote the screenplay for "Weird:
The Al Yankovic" story, along
with "Weird Al" Yankovic himself.
A teaser for "Weird: The Al Yankovic Story"
arrived in May of 2022. It kicks off with a
concert venue preparing for what appears
to be a huge act. The crowd is on their
feet as they await the musician they're
all there to see, and in mere moments,
they get their wish. "Weird Al" Yankovic emerges
on stage — accordion in hand — and prepares to put
on a show. The 1986 track "Like A Surgeon" begins
to play over a string of clips from the film.
While not revealing much about the plot, the
montage does provide some interesting tidbits.
Yankovic performs at various venues, dazzles
onlookers with his music and dance skills,
and even gets into a heated fight at a
restaurant. A stern Yankovic then asks
if anyone has an accordion, prompting
three people to hand him an instrument
simultaneously. The teaser closes with the
title card and the lead character confessing,
"I'm full of surprises."
In August 2022, the full trailer for the movie
hit the internet, revealing more plot beats,
moments, and characters. With Daniel Radcliffe
narrating, the preview argues that "Weird" is
the origin story of a legendary musician,
showing that he partied harder than anyone.
You can spy Will Forte and the real "Weird
Al" Yankovic at the end if you look closely.
Within a few days of the screening of the
"Weird: The Al Yankovic Story" at the Toronto
International Film Festival, movie critics began
to publish their reviews. According to Rotten
Tomatoes, it appears as if "Weird" just might be a
critical darling, earning an exemplary 92% rating.
David Fear of Rolling Stone praised the film
as an extension of the "Weird Al" brand:
"Like the artist himself, 'Weird' knows how
to make fun of something with affection,
the [occasional] dollop of
barbed wit and a knack for
making imitation seem like the
sincerest form of creativity."
Slant's Mark Hanson wrote that the
film "takes everything to new heights
of glorious ridiculousness." Valerie Complex
of Deadline enjoyed the wide array of cameos,
while David Nusair of Reel Film Reviews gushed
over Daniel Radcliffe's "completely
captivating, go-for-broke performance."